peintures sculptures ou des seins des
dizaines de techniques pour une même
exposition guyancourt a rassemblé plus
de 80 artistes
une manière de célébrer la diversité des
arts visuels
parmi les travaux exposés ceux de daniel
convenant ce peintre de versailles créé
ses toiles avec du bitume
c'est un noir profond est contente qu'on
peut diluer à l'infini et chutera comme
une à croix je travaille après une après
une période de réflexion
c'est plus ou moins long ça peut durer
quelques temps que le jour où une
semaine les tableaux de daniel convenant
font partie des oeuvres sélectionnées
par un jury de professionnels claude
champy est invité d'honneur de cette
deuxième édition d'art talent l'artiste
exposé dans le monde entier et a reçu de
nombreux prix son travail se tournent
plutôt vers le minéral chez lui répondit
ou ou le fâche availles la porsche à la
lauch imap à cela même pour moi c'est la
même chose si les mêmes températures de
cuisson seul je cherche à raconter à
faire parler du jour là la matière jean
il ya toujours une volonté peut-être à
peu prétentieuse mais de la cheminée
comme mon boulot ça peut être des
clauses y ont justement je le soleil la
lave
samedi 13 mère nathalie et d'écriture
artistique animé par l'un des membres du
jury est proposé aux visiteurs
ils peuvent également participer au prix
du public en votant pour l'oeuvre de
leur choix